vamos a hablar de osciladores y que es
un oscilador es un objeto o variable que
se puede mover adelante y hacia atrás o
aumentar o decrementar ir de arriba a
abajo de izquierda a derecha una y otra
y otra vez por ejemplo aquí tenemos una
masa conectada a un resorte es un
oscilador porque si jalamos la masa
hacia la derecha este resorte hará que
la masa oscile adelante y hacia atrás
una y otra vez y es a esto a lo que nos
referimos con un oscilador otro ejemplo
común es el péndulo un péndulo es una
masa conectada a una cuerda fija la más
la más hacia un lado esta va a regresar
y va a estar moviéndose de un lado a
otro una y otra vez así que esto es un
oscilador y estos son los tipos más
comunes de osciladores la masa en un
resorte y el péndulo pero hay muchos
otros ejemplos y todos estos ejemplos
comparten una característica en común
que los define como osciladores y
ustedes se preguntarán bueno por qué es
que estas cosas oscilan en primer lugar
es por el hecho de que comparten esta
característica
todos tienen una fuerza restauradora y
la fuerza restauradora como lo sugiere
su nombre trata de restaurar el sistema
restaurar lo que se preguntarán pues
restaurar el sistema a su posición de
equilibrio todo oscilador tiene una
posición de equilibrio y ese punto es en
donde no tenemos una fuerza neta en ese
objeto por ejemplo para esta masa en
este resorte si tenemos que se encuentra
en su posición de equilibrio la fuerza
neta en ese objeto será de 0 ya que esto
es lo que significa la posición de
equilibrio en otras palabras si dejamos
la más aquí aquí se va a quedar ya que
no tiene alguna fuerza neta en ella sin
embargo si yo halo esta masa hacia la
derecha
el resorte va a decir ah no esto no me
gusta voy a tratar de restaurar esta
masa en la posición de equilibrio
regresarla a donde estaba así que el
resorte va a jalar hacia la izquierda
y si yo empujo la masa hacia la
izquierda el resorte va a decir esto no
me gusta vamos a regresar esto a su
posición de equilibrio así que si yo
empujó hacia la izquierda el resorte va
a empujar hacia la derecha y si yo jaló
hacia la derecha
el resorte va a jalar hacia la izquierda
siempre va a tratar de restaurar a la
masa en la posición de equilibrio lo
mismo sucede con el péndulo si yo muevo
el péndulo hacia la derecha
la gravedad va a actuar como fuerza
restauradora y la va a tratar de
regresar hacia la izquierda pero si jalo
la masa hacia la izquierda la gravedad
va a tratar de regresarlo a su posición
de equilibrio moviéndola hacia la
derecha siempre va a tratar de regresar
la masa a su posición de equilibrio y
esto es a lo que nos referimos cuando
hablamos de fuerzas restauradoras ahora
hay muchos tipos de osciladores pero
solo algunos de estos son
especiales y les damos un término
especial los llamamos osciladores
armónicos simples y ustedes pueden
pensar a qué nombre tan más ridículo ya
que eso no suena simple para nada pero
existe algo llamado oscilador armónico
simple y que es lo que hace a estos
osciladores armónicos simples tan
especiales resulta que aunque todos los
osciladores tienen una fuerza
restauradora los osciladores armónicos
simples tienen una fuerza restauradora
que es proporcional al desplazamiento
esto quiere decir que si yo halo está
más hacia la derecha habrá una fuerza
restauradora pero que será proporcional
al desplazamiento que yo hice con esta
masa si yo jalo esta masa hacia la
derecha el doble que la primera vez voy
a obtener el doble de la fuerza
restauradora y si la halo tres veces más
voy a obtener el triple de la fuerza
restauradora lo mismo aquí abajo si yo
jalo esta masa
es el ángulo de la primera vez voy a
obtener el doble de la fuerza
restauradora que tuve la primera vez si
esto se cumple entonces tenemos un
oscilador armónico simple y quizá esto
aún no los impresiones digan bueno y a
quién le interesa esto porque me debe
interesar que la fuerza restauradora sea
proporcional al desplazamiento bueno
esto nos interesa porque estos
osciladores cumplen una regla muy
especial la cual veremos en este vídeo y
aunque esto no suene demasiado simple
créanme que son mucho más simples que
las alternativas de los osciladores que
no son armónicos simples estos son los
que normalmente estudiamos en las clases
introductorias de física y resulta que
una masa en un resorte es un oscilador
armónico simple y el péndulo también
aunque sólo para oscilaciones pequeñas
aunque aquí debemos decir que es sólo
para ángulos pequeños pero para ángulos
pequeños el péndulo es un oscilador
armónico simple m
vídeo solo vamos a analizar la masa en
el resorte y en otro vídeo veremos el
péndulo quitamos el péndulo para
enfocarnos en la masa en el resorte y
quizás ustedes no estén convencidos de
que esta masa en el resorte sea un
oscilador armónico simple bueno podemos
probarlo porque la fuerza que
proporciona a la fuerza restauradora en
este caso es el resorte el resorte es la
fuerza restauradora en este caso y
conocemos la fórmula de la fuerza del
resorte que está dada por la ley de hook
y la ley de nos dice que la fuerza
proporcionada por el resorte fs para el
resorte va a ser negativa la constante
del resorte k multiplicada por x que es
el desplazamiento del resorte así que x
va a ser positiva si el resorte se
desplaza hacia la derecha el resorte se
va a ser más largo así que este es un
desplazamiento positivo
y si comprimimos el resorte la longitud
del resorte va a ser menor y vamos a
tener que se desplazó a la izquierda que
tomaremos como un valor negativo de x
piensen en esto si yo comprime el
resorte hacia la izquierda mi x va a ser
negativa y este negativo con el otro
negativo que tengo acá va a ser que mi
fuerza en total sea positiva por lo que
voy a obtener una fuerza positiva lo que
quiere decir que el resorte se va a
mover hacia la derecha y esto tiene
sentido restauradora quiere decir que se
va a oponer a lo que uno haga si
empujamos la masa hacia la izquierda
el resorte va a querer empujarla hacia
la derecha si lo hacemos de la otra
manera jalamos la masa hacia la derecha
el resorte va a querer jalar esta masa
hacia la izquierda si tengo un valor de
x positivo y lo pongo aquí la fuerza
resultante va a ser una fuerza negativa
es decir que el resorte va a querer
jalar la masa hacia el lado izquierdo va
a restaurar esta masa a su posición de
equilibrio
esto es exactamente lo que hace uno si
la dos y vean que esta fuerza del
resorte esta fuerza restauradora es
proporcional al desplazamiento este es
el desplazamiento y esta es la
definición de el oscilador armónico
simple y es por esto que las masas en
los resortes van a ser osciladores
armónicos simples ya que la fuerza
restauradora es proporcional al
desplazamiento aunque bueno siendo
honestos tendrá que ser
proporcionalmente negativa al
desplazamiento si tuviéramos efe igual
acá por equis sin tener el signo
negativo y desplazamos la masa a la
derecha la fuerza tendría dirección
también hacia la derecha lo que
ocasionaría un mayor desplazamiento
hacia la derecha lo que a su vez crearía
una mayor fuerza hacia la derecha y esto
finalmente no tendría fin sería
eternamente empujando la masa hacia la
derecha
lo cual no sería bueno así que son
realmente fuerzas que tienen una
proporción negativa al desplazamiento de
esta manera va a restaurar la masa a la
posición de equilibrio y si esto es
proporcional al desplazamiento entonces
tendremos un oscilador armónico simple y
bueno a qué nos referimos con que sea
simple esto que tiene de simple bueno
resulta que estos tipos de osciladores
pueden describirse usando funciones seno
y cosenos los osciladores armónicos
simples van a ser descritos usando seno
o coseno lo que tiene sentido ya que si
recuerdan cómo se ven las funciones
senos y cosenos lucen algo así así se ve
el seno y el cose no comienza por acá y
luce así son funciones que oscilan una y
otra vez y pues resulta que estas son
funciones sencillas ya que oscilan una y
otra vez y a los físicos les gustan
mucho estas funciones nos encantan las
cosas que son descritas por el seno o el
coseno
ya que son bastantes sencillas de
trabajar matemáticamente y aunque quizás
ustedes no piensen igual créanme que son
mucho más sencillas que las alternativas
de otras cosas que también oscilan y eso
es lo que significa oscilador armónico
simple pero tratemos de encontrar una
intuición sobre esto qué es lo que está
sucediendo en esta masa bueno imaginemos
que jalamos esta masa conectada al
resorte hacia la derecha ya que si
dejáramos a la masa tranquilita en su
posición de equilibrio cuál sería un
problema bastante aburrido ya que su
fuerza neta sería de cero y la masa
continuaría en ese lugar así que jalamos
esta masa hacia atrás cierto
desplazamiento y luego la soltamos y ya
que soltamos la masa la vamos a liberar
cuando está en reposo y como estaba en
reposo quiere decir que la rapidez
inicial era de cero así que comienza con
una rapidez de cero pero
este resorte se ha estirado y este va a
tratar de restaurar la masa a su
posición de equilibrio así que el
resorte va a jalar la masa hacia la
izquierda incrementando su rapidez e
incrementa la rapidez de la masa hasta
que llega a la posición de equilibrio y
en ese momento el resorte se da cuenta
de que chispas quería regresar a esta
masa en esta posición pero lo hice con
demasiada fuerza y ahora esta masa tiene
mucha rapidez hacia la izquierda y las
masas no se detienen por sí solas
necesitan de una fuerza para hacerlo
esta masa tiene inercia y de acuerdo a
la primera ley de newton esta masa va a
tratar de seguir moviéndose así que
aunque el resorte haya llevado la masa
de nuevo a su posición de equilibrio
pero la llevo ahí con una gran rapidez y
la inercia de la masa va a hacer que
pase más allá de la posición de
equilibrio y ahora el resorte se va a
comprimir y ahora el resorte dice uy
ahora tengo que regresar esta masa su
posición de equilibrio y la
empujar hacia la derecha así que ahora
el resorte empuja hacia la derecha
haciendo que la rapidez de la masa
disminuye hasta que se detiene pero como
el resorte está comprimido va a seguir
empujando hacia la derecha para ahora
llevar a la masa en la dirección opuesta
de su movimiento y regresarla a su
posición de equilibrio lo cual es lo que
el resorte quiere pero de nuevo sucede
el mismo error
el resorte lleva esta masa a la posición
de equilibrio con una gran rapidez hacia
la derecha y ahora el resorte dice ay lo
volvió a hacer lleve a la masa a donde
quería pero esta masa tiene una gran
rapidez y tiene inercia así que la masa
va a continuar moviéndose hacia la
derecha más allá de la posición de
equilibrio y es por esto que ocurre la
oscilación es una lucha constante entre
la inercia de la masa que hace que se
siga moviendo ya que tiene masa y tiene
rapidez y entre la fuerza restauradora
que está tratando desesperadamente de
regresar la masa
su posición de equilibrio lo cual le
cuesta trabajo realizar ya que se sigue
excediendo en empujarla o en jalar la
por lo que esta oscilación ocurre una y
otra vez y ahora que ya comprendimos
como ocurre esto ahora mencionemos
algunas cosas importantes sobre la
oscilación una de ellas es que en estos
puntos terminales los puntos de máxima
compresión o máxima extensión la rapidez
es cero por lo que esta masa se va a
mover lo más despacio aquí y de hecho en
este punto no se está moviendo en estos
lugares de máxima compresión o máxima
extensión porque es en esos puntos en
donde el resorte ha detenido a la masa y
comienza a llevarla hacia la dirección
contraria y en cambio a la mitad justo a
la posición de equilibrio tenemos la
mayor rapidez aquí es en donde la masa
se mueve más rápidamente cuando la masa
regresado a la posición de equilibrio y
es en ese punto cuando el resorte se da
cuenta de que chispas la masa va a
continuar moviéndose más
donde quería dejarla así que es la
posición de equilibrio donde la masa
tiene la mayor rapidez al menos durante
la oscilación y también nos podemos
preguntar cuál será la magnitud de la
fuerza restauradora en qué punto esta
magnitud será mayor y en qué punto esta
magnitud será menor al menos durante
esta oscilación pues aquí tenemos la
fórmula la fuerza del resorte es la
fuerza restauradora así que nos
preguntamos en qué punto esta fuerza o
su magnitud va a ser mayor y en qué
punto va a ser menor pues será en el
punto en el que este x sea mayor o menor
si nos interesa conocer la magnitud de
ésta fs si queremos conocer cuál será la
magnitud más grande de ésta fs pues va a
ser cuando tengamos una x mayor si no
nos interesa la dirección de esta fuerza
y sólo queremos saber dónde vamos a
tener una gran fuerza pues tratemos de
encontrar en donde vamos a tener nuestra
equis más grande x es el desplazamiento
el val
x de x en la posición de equilibrio es
igual a 0 por lo que aquí no tenemos
ningún desplazamiento del resorte justo
es lo que significa la posición de
equilibrio
esta es la longitud natural del resorte
es la longitud a la que el resorte
quiere estar por lo que no va a empujar
ni a jalas pero si desplazamos el
resorte en esta dirección o en la otra
dirección esta sería un desplazamiento
positivo y este de acá sería un
desplazamiento negativo ahora el resorte
va a ejercer una fuerza en donde será
mayor esta fuerza pues en donde el
resorte haya sido comprimido o extendido
en mayor cantidad así que en estos
puntos de acá los puntos de máxima
extensión o compresión tendremos la
mayor magnitud de fuerza ya que cuando
estiramos mucho el resorte el resorte va
a jalar con mucha mayor fuerza para
llevar a la masa a la posición de
equilibrio y como sabemos la dirección a
quien resorte va a ejercer una gran
fuerza
hacia la izquierda y técnicamente sería
una fuerza negativa y si ustedes toman
en cuenta la ciencia podrían decir que
aquí se encuentra la menor cantidad de
fuerza porque es bastante negativa pero
si nos interesa solamente la magnitud
aquí tendremos una gran magnitud de
fuerza y también aquí en el punto de
mayor compresión el resorte va a estar
empujando la masa a la derecha con una
gran fuerza ya que aunque nuestra x es
bastante negativa en este punto nos va a
dar una gran cantidad de fuerza así que
aquí también tendremos una gran magnitud
de la fuerza del resorte lo que puede
ser confuso ya que vean en estos puntos
terminales la rapidez es de cero tenemos
la menor cantidad de rapidez pero
tenemos la mayor cantidad de fuerza y
esto a veces confunde a las personas ya
que piensan cómo es posible tener una
gran fuerza con una rapidez tan pequeña
bueno ese es el punto en donde el
resorte ha detenido a la masa y está
comenzando a jalarla en la dirección
contraria así que
aunque la rapidez sea de 0 la fuerza es
mayor así que tengan cuidado la fuerza
no tiene que ser proporcional a la
rapidez la fuerza tiene que ser
proporcional a la aceleración ya que
sabemos que la fuerza neta es igual a m
por a así que en donde tenemos la mayor
cantidad de fuerza vamos a tener la
mayor cantidad de aceleración por lo que
podemos decir que en estos puntos
terminales no tendremos solamente la
mayor magnitud de la fuerza sino también
la mayor magnitud de la aceleración ya
que sea que estamos empujando o jalando
algo con la mayor cantidad de fuerza
tendremos la mayor cantidad de
aceleración de acuerdo con la segunda
ley de newton así que en estos puntos
terminales o puntos extremos tendremos
la mayor cantidad de fuerza y la mayor
cantidad de aceleración aun cuando
tengamos una rapidez de 0 así que estos
son los puntos en donde tendremos la
mayor cantidad de fuerza y la mayor
cantidad de aceleración en donde
tendremos la menor cantidad de fuerza y
la menor cantidad de acelera
pues vemos la fórmula de nuevo tendremos
la menor cantidad de fuerza cuando
tengamos la menor cantidad de
desplazamiento y la menor cantidad de
desplazamiento es justo aquí en el medio
en la posición de equilibrio la posición
de equilibrio está donde x es igual a 0
que es cuando el resorte me empujan y
jala justo cuando la masa está pasando a
través de la posición de equilibrio aquí
tendremos una fuerza igual a cero es el
punto en el que la masa regresa a su
posición de equilibrio y el resorte dice
vaya por fin lo logré aunque después el
resorte se da cuenta de que no fue así
regresó la masa a esa posición pero la
masa continúa moviéndose así que pasa
más allá de este punto pero justo en
este punto el resorte tiene este momento
de gloria en donde piensa que logró
regresar la masa a su posición de
equilibrio y deja de ejercer la fuerza
porque en ese punto x es igual a cero y
si x es igual a cero
vemos que la fuerza también será igual a
cero
así que aquí tendremos la menor cantidad
de fuerza aunque debería decir que esta
es una fuerza de 0 no es la menor es
igual a 0 y si la fuerza es 0 usando el
mismo argumento podemos decir que la
aceleración también va a ser cero espero
que esto les haya dado una intuición del
por qué los osciladores hacen lo que
hacen y en dónde podemos encontrar la
mayor rapidez o fuerza en cierto punto
en resumen los objetos que tienen una
fuerza de restauradora negativamente
proporcional al desplazamiento serán
osciladores armónicos simples y para
todos los osciladores armónicos simples
en la posición de equilibrio tendremos
la mayor rapidez pero cero fuerza
restauradora y cero aceleración mientras
que en los puntos de máximo
desplazamiento tendremos la mayor
magnitud de fuerza restauradora y
aceleración
la menor cantidad de rapidez posible